Achtung wer noch nicht geimpfte sollte
sich dieses Video auf keinen Fall
anschauen
meinst das funktioniert jetzt im Ernst
das ist ein Video vor allem an alle
geimpften an alle die im Kontakte
reduziert haben die verzichtet haben die
vieles auf sich genommen haben die müde
sind sie wütend sind und sie sich jetzt
fragen was hat das alles gebracht warum
sind wir scheinbar immer noch da wo wir
letztes Jahr waren und geht das jetzt
für immer so weiter nein
zumindest nicht wenn wir jetzt das
richtige tun auch wenn sich so anfühlt
wie und täglich grüßt das Murmeltier ist
unsere jetzige Situation doch sehr
anders als letztes Jahr und erst wenn
wir verstanden haben inwieweit diese
Welle anders ist als alle anderen können
wir vernünftig handeln und die Pandemie
so schnell und so gesund wie möglich
beenden also keine Panik holt euch den
Tee wir steigen durch
lasst uns anfangen mit einer kurzen
Wiederholung weiß sehr wichtig ist wisst
ihr noch am Anfang der Pandemie was
überall von flat and the curve die Rede
war die infektions Kurve flach halten
wir wollten verhindern dass unser
Gesundheitssystem zusammenbricht was wir
leider gerade in Italien Spanien oder
New York mit Schrecken beobachten wenn
die Intensivstation nicht mehr genug
Betten für alle Patienten haben dann
müssen schrecklich Entscheidung über
Leben und Tod getroffen werden das darf
nicht passieren sollen wir hier ist die
Belastungsgrenze der Intensivstation die
übrigens nicht in erster Linie von der
Anzahl der Betten abhängt sondern von
speziell geschulten und völlig
überarbeitet impersonal jedes Reiskorn
steht für einen Menschen der nach einer
covid-19 Infektion auf der
Intensivstation landet lassen wir das
Virus einfach so durch rauschen ohne was
zu unternehmen also ja Mittelalter
solchen Style sieht der zeitliche
Verlauf der Intensiv Erde so aus kurz
und extrem schmerzhaft weil dabei das
Gesundheitssystem kollabiert deswegen
lautete am Anfang der Pandemie die
Devise flat and the curve die
Infektionszahlen unter die
Belastungsgrenze des Gesundheitssystems
drücken das Problem war nur dass die
Grenze nicht hier lag sondern eher hier
und um den Führungskurve so krass zu
drücken braucht es krasse Kontakt
Einschränkungen und je flacher die Kurve
desto länger dauert in den Zusammenbruch
unseres Gesundheitssystems zu vermeiden
müssen wir strenge Maßnahmen für ein bis
zwei Jahre lang aufrechterhalten und das
geht nicht wir sehen ja jetzt schon
welche immensen Schäden für die
Volkswirtschaft erwarten sind da häng
Existenz und damit auch wieder
Menschenleben dran und auch welche
allgemeinen gesellschaftlichen auch
psychologischen Freund das hätte
langfristig das können wir derzeit noch
gar nicht fassen ja inzwischen damit
besser fassen irgendwas wurde klar fände
curve ist nicht so lange hält das keiner
aus aus flat in the curve wurde stop the
curve wir müssen die Kurve stoppen wie
idealerweise mit einem sofortigen
schmerzhaften aber dafür kurzen Lockdown
detektions Zahlen so stark runter zu
drücken das wieder jede Infektion
nachverfolgt werden kann und jede neue
Infektionskette gebrochen werden kann
dann würde für viele Menschen wieder so
etwas wie Normalität zurückkehren denn
dann wären die strengen Maßnahmen wieder
nur gezielt auf die erkrankten und ihre
Kontaktperson konzentriert in so einem
Zustand lässt es sich nämlich erträglich
bis zum Impfstoff ausharren im Sommer
2020 waren wir nah dran an diesem
Idealzustand doch wir haben wir nicht
gehalten sondern haben eine zweite Welle
zugelassen und eine dritte und jetzt
eben eine vierte wo der Unterschied
jetzt jetzt ist der Impfstoff da wie
gesagt dass sie es ein video für
geimpfte ich brauche euch nicht vom
Impfen zu überzeugen aber der nächste
Abschnitt ist wichtig um zu verstehen
wieso diese Welle anders ist als die
bisherigen und was deswegen jetzt zu tun
ist impfen ist der beste Käse im 816
aber ich verrät vom Käsescheiben oder
habt ihr vielleicht schon gehört wir
haben ja inzwischen unterschiedlichste
Möglichkeiten das infektions geschehen
zu bremsen Masken Abstand Schnelltest
Homeoffice 2G 3G uname keine dieser
Maßnahmen ist perfekt darin Infektion zu
verhindern jeder hat so ihre Mängel
welche unter der Kurve bleibt gleich
Infektionen werden nicht verhindert
sondern nur verzögert sobald wir mit den
Masken und im Test und so weiter
aufhören nehmen wir ja die Käsescheiben
wieder weg und das Infektionsrisiko
steigt wieder nur die Impfung kann
Infektionen nicht auf verzögern sondern
auch wirklich vermeiden ja die Info wird
nicht zu 100% auch sie ist eine
Käsescheibe mit Löchern aber sie ist der
einzige Käse der bleibt
Hartkäse sozusagen die
Fläche unter der Kurve kleiner und die
Höhe die Impfquote und die wirksame der
Impfschutz desto weniger Menschen landen
auf der Intensivstation die Impfung
rettet Leben und macht die Pandemie
Kürze ja ja mei aber wenn in von doch so
Toys warum ist da gerade alles so
scheiße sehr gute Frage warum ist gerade
alles so scheiße und das obwohl ja stand
heute immerhin mehr als zwei Drittel der
Bevölkerung vollständig geimpft ist hat
es den gar nichts gebracht erstmal doch
wir konnten durch die Impfung schon
einige Reiskörner entfernen also viele
Infektionen intensiv Aufenthalte und
Todesfälle vermeiden was die Lage
bereits entspannt hat das heißt ohne
Impfung wäre alles gerade noch sehr viel
beschissener warum es aber noch nicht
gut ist noch nicht vorbei ist liegt
daran dass die impflücke noch viel zu
groß ist tatsächlich muss die impflüge
fast vollständig geschlossen werden
damit diese Pandemie vorbei ist hatten
wir am Anfang der Pandemie noch
optimistischer Aussichten da dachten
viele wenn man so 70-80 Protze der Leute
geben statt ist der Drops gelutscht
warum das jetzt nicht so ist liegt vor
allem an drei Dingen erstens Delta die
aktuelle Delta Variante des Virus die
seit Sommer 2021 Deutschland übernommen
hat ist doch ansteckender das heißt man
braucht eine höhere Impfquote für den
gleichen Infektionsschutz zweitens keine
sterilisierende Immunität der geimpft
oder genießen ist kann sich oder andere
wenn noch mit reduziertem Risiko immer
noch anstecken wir haben hier also keine
sogenannte sterilisierende Immunität
diese Formel für die herdenimmunität nur
wenn eine durchgemachte
komplett gegeben
vollständig geimpft gibt es viele
Menschen deren Impfung 5 6 Monate her
ist und in Sachen Zahlen frisch nach der
Impfung mit bei und textiles nennen ist
der Schutz etwa 90% und dann fünf Monate
später nur noch 50 bis 70% am Anfang ist
es in factor10 Schutz und jetzt ist es
nur noch ein Faktor 2 bis 3 und das
macht für die Ausbreitung großen
Unterschied und damit natürlich dann
auch für die Intensivstation dass die
Immunität nach einer Impfung oder
Erkrankung abnehmen kann es übrigens
nichts super Ungewöhnliches und auch
etwas womit man auch schon vorgerechnet
hat außerdem ist diese Impfung
vielleicht gar nicht die einzige die es
geben wird vielleicht wird eine saisonal
Impfung vielleicht gibt's im Herbst oder
vielleicht muss man sowieso irgendwann
noch mal impfen weil die Impfungen sich
an die neuen Mutation anpassen müssen ob
sie jetzt mit der dritten boosterimpfung
erledigt ist erstmal oder ob es dann
noch eine Info gibt ob es was saisonales
wird wie bei der Grippeimpfung dann
wahrscheinlich eher nur für
Risikogruppen weiß man derzeit noch
nicht so oder so gilt impfen impfen
impfen Bambus Bambus dann wir brauchen
mehr im Paula kommt die jetzt nicht zu
spät ist die vierte Welle nicht von ihr
verloren erstmal nur weil wir leben
pflücken nicht sofort schließen können
heißt es ja nicht dass nicht jedes
Prozent Impfquote die Lage besser macht
aber vor allem die 4. Welle ist nicht
unbedingt die letzte ja es könnte noch
eine fünfte oder sogar sechste werde
geben das was Gesundheitsminister Jens
Spahn am Montag sagte
aber es ist tatsächlich hier so
das sollte wahrscheinlich die Notlage
deutlich machen ist aber mindestens mal
missverständlich war das so klingt als
wäre diese Welle die letzte als sei die
Impfung noch diesen Winter Thema oder
nach ist egal wer danach eh durch soll
ich das so ist es aber nicht um so eine
Durchseuchung zu schaffen müsste man so
viele intensiv werde und Todesfälle
zulassen sind das wäre dann schon fast
Mittelalter Seuchen Style das wird man
nicht zulassen zum Glück zum Pech
wiederum das auch ein weiterer Lockdown
nicht auszuschließen ist unser stehen
zur zu verhindern da wir dass wir uns
nicht ausrotten werden sondern sie
heimisch werden wird wird es sogar
wahrscheinlich gehen Winter eine Welle
die die Frage ist nur wird diese Welle
so groß dass wir wieder zusätzlich
Kontakte einschränken und Sachen
schließen müssen das hängt einzig und
allein von der Immunität unserer
Bevölkerung ab und Immunität erreicht
man eben nicht durch Durchseuchung aus
eben genannten Gründen sondern durch
durch Impfung ich sag's noch mal anders
wenn wir die Impfquote auf dem aktuellen
Niveau dümpeln das nonstop ich lauf
durch solche umsetzen wird nicht das was
wir gerade erleben in der weiteren werde
durchaus noch mal wiederholen wir
brauchen also volle im Power die
Realität ist aber dass wir diese im
Power noch nicht aktiviert haben und wir
alle sich jetzt fragen aber was kann ich
denn jetzt noch tun außer mich Boostern
lassen ja es liegt jetzt in der
Verantwortung der Regierung Liebe
Regierung die impflüge so schnell wie
möglich zu schließen aber bis dahin
können wir alle müssen wir alle noch was
tun denn bis dahin gilt glättende curve
ist Bergleute das was am Anfang der
Pandemie als unrealistisch Geld nämlich
Infektionszahlen solange niedrig zu
halten bis die Panini vorbei ist ist
jetzt nicht nur wieder möglich sondern
auch bitter nötig denn
sie wissen ja auch
weniger intensiv
bitte auch ein intensivbett und es ist
in jeder Region Deutschlands bereits in
jeder jetzt wo wir hier sprechen ist die
normale Versorgung nicht mehr gesichert
wie wir das kennen
Endspurt und nochwas bitte lasst euch
nicht anstecken vor dem Hass den manche
Menschen momentan zur Schau tragen
da machen wir nicht mit Öl
Menschlichkeiten Hass sind ein genauso
schlimmes Virus Wiese aus Gruppe 2 macht
es euren Mitmenschen leicht ihre Meinung
zu ändern beschimpft nicht das hat auch
nie irgendjemanden überzeugt und seid
nicht Helme wenn manche zu spät oder aus
den falschen Gründen ihre Meinung ändern
sich doch impfen lassen sondern freut
euch einfach für Sie und für die
Impfquote weiter wir müssen es jetzt
schaffen